regardless of how much money it is that
Washington ends up doing we're going to
start spending on infrastructure big it
can't be done effectively without
public/private partnerships
hi I'm Nick Gillespie with reason today
we are talking with Steven goldsmith the
former mayor of Indianapolis who is one
the newest reason Sophos word for
pushing public-private partnerships
Mayor Ultima thanks for talking to us
sure you were mayor of Indianapolis from
1992 to 2000 special advisor to George W
Bush deputy mayor of New York and you're
now a professor of government at
Harvard's Kennedy School and most
recently the author of the responsive
city which came out in 2014 and we'll
talk about that in a second at your time
in Indianapolis you save taxpayers about
four hundred million dollars by
privatizing what was the impetus for
that where did the idea is correct right
well I think we answer that in two
different ways first I became mayor we
had a structural deficit in the budget
and we had a Chamber of Commerce report
saying we need a billion dollars in
infrastructure and our property taxes
were higher than our suburbs right so
you can't raise taxes is not good for
the economy we need to rebuild the
infrastructure so what do you do well
you become as efficient as you can and
the goal then was to reduce the
operating cost of government and
transfer that into an investment in the
infrastructure of the future for the
city so those were the conditions the
ideas about how to get there frankly
were firm reason you know a bob pol
spent I don't know how many lunches in
Indianapolis when I was running for
mayor and after I got elected kind of
going through a tizzy and how to
privatize and the talk about that you
didn't just go through a tizzy you went
through the phonebook with a disease
right and what what was the rubric that
you use to see whether or not the
government should be the sole provider
of a good right so thanks so the goal
was not to privatize the goal was to be
as efficient and effective as possible
sometimes that meant you continue to do
things the way you always done not very
often but sometimes other times it meant
you had privatize the asset other times
it means you set up manage competition
so labor would have to bid on continue
to do the work they've done
become more productive I generally found
that if we very sophisticated test open
up the phonebook and the yellow pages if
there are three or more other businesses
in the same area in your city you're
probably not the most efficient provider
of those services and we bit out or did
manage competition over eighty times you
know many cities today in America
obviously are you know facing structural
deficits are they following the the path
that you blazed in Indianapolis and if
not what what's the biggest problem is
it not knowing how to do that or is it
political interest getting in the water
I think the basic problem is an
understanding of the goal right the goal
isn't to monetize assets so you bring
all of the revenues forward like parking
meters and then spend it on operating
the goal is efficiency right so how do
you operate something more efficiently
is there anybody in the world better
than you are in your city at operating
streetlights or parking our golf courses
or water or wastewater or airports then
you take the savings and invest that in
future to say so I think the thing
that's holding people back is that
they're thinking about it as do we want
to privatize do we want to sell the
family jewels as contrasted you what is
the role of government in terms of
managing that asset was a specific asset
or thing that Indianapolis was doing and
how did you shift it into a more
efficient mode right so we did about 80
of these either managed competition or
privatization we did the first large
wastewater privatization in the country
you know today there are tens of
billions of dollars of mandates against
local and authorities for water and
wastewater EPA compliance and the like
so the city needs to clean its water
right there are environmental
responsibilities Indianapolis at the
time according to Ernst and Young was
one of the most efficiently run
wastewater treatment plants in the
country and yet then we went ahead and
asked for anybody in the world to give
us a bit about how to manage our plan
and it turns out that the winning bidder
had more PhDs and we had employs right
there was no way that we were as
effective as they were there's no way we
had the best technology the way we had
the best management so essentially then
they managed the plants for about 25 to
30 percent less per year which produced
a you know a savings that we could then
use
debt or efficiency purposes for some
other reason to invest it in the
infrastructure of the city are there any
big mistakes that you made where either
the privatization or failing to do that
just blew out right if you continue to
do a mediocre service and don't change
the status quo you generally don't get
criticized if you try to change the
status quo let's say it's like this and
you go like this that you wanted to go
like this it's often viewed as a failure
still better than it was before but not
as good so one of the most important
lessons we learned was benchmark
everything before you begin benchmark in
terms of quality and benchmarking in
terms of cost and occasionally we
slipped up on that the other issue which
I don't think is a mistake but we did
make mistakes and not a mistake in terms
of we shouldn't have done it is what are
the service level requirements after you
privatize the asset right what do you
want the experience to be for passengers
in the airport what do you want to and
the quality of the water to be how high
do you want the grass to be after you
privatize the mowing of the medians so
get the service levels right get the
benchmarks where you have the numbers
right and then you can do it correctly
and occasionally got those wrong let's
talk about the next frontiers in public
private partnerships or making I mean
actually it's more making government
more efficient how does the responsive
City your 2014 book deal with that or
where what what is that about so I think
we're in a really interesting moment
where public-private partnerships could
blossom in a pretty dramatic way so if
we have technologies that are highly
refined let's say go back to water and
waste water so it puts sensors in pipes
we know where the leaks are we know
where the pressure is we know when the
water hydrant is going to be low you
know we can anticipate a problem and fix
it before it occurs we have a sensor on
a bridge it says this bridge is
vibrating too much in Minneapolis but
you know it's going to fall down if you
don't come fix it right a streetlight
that says I'm about to burn out come fix
me before I burn out right so the
public-private partnerships and what we
talked about in responsive City is how
to use data how to use data analytics
how to use sensors in order to
anticipate problems and solve them
before they become serious what are the
chief impediments to pushing forward on
using big data
on using you know pushing this forward
where is where's the resistance the
impediments generally are perceived to
be is this hostile to labor and our
experience was it wasn't hostile to
labor at all in fact our labor as they
became more productive earn more money
what we said is we don't need as many
managers and we need more technology so
as we look at the uses of technology
we're having a pretty high attrition and
retirement rate in the public service
right because of the age of the average
public employee so you don't have to
layoff anyone we're we're basically
saying to employees is as a result of
partnering with the private sector as a
result of getting more technology as a
result of using predictive analytics and
sensors we can make your work more
effective therefore you win and the
taxpayer and as workers in the public
sector like the private sector generally
as have become more productive which
technology helps what they'll be paid
one none of that 400 million dollars we
saved was from reducing the wages of
employees employees at ridded they
retired they may have decided they
didn't want to work as hard as the
private sector made them work
the managers thinned out but what
happened is they became so much more
productive that they could win and the
taxpayers could win and data and
technology and mobile devices and the
like let you do that today in ways that
we hadn't even dreamed of looking at a
national level
Donald Trump has talked about a trillion
dollar infrastructure investment program
not clear what the details are anything
is that the type of thing that should be
done exclusively through public-private
partnerships right so if you look at
public-private partnerships and you
think about this trillion dollars and
everyone's a little confused about what
the trillion dollars is but somebody's
got to pay back that money right the
problem with infrastructure is not that
you can't borrow the money there's
plenty of people willing to loan you the
money but but a mayor or governor has to
pay the money back so if we thought
about public-private partnerships the
following things happen a there is money
locked in those assets like water or
wastewater or airports that could be
taken out of operations more effectively
and used for debt service they like to
if you do public-private partnerships
you build faster and less expensively
there with more value engineering and
three you have life cycle costing so
regardless of how much money it is that
Washington ends up doing and I've got to
know how much that will be
can't be done effectively without
public-private partnerships both for
purposes of paying back the money and
for purposes of maintaining this and
kind of getting the money in the first
place right I mean you you can always
borrow but if there are firms that are
willing to build roads or expand Road
capacity or take over water treatment
they're putting in a lot of the money
right
well yeah further they are willing to
put money into equity they want to
partially own these assets those same
firms are saying look I'll maintain that
asset for 20 years you don't have to
worry about me building it in an
inferior way so that the cost of
maintenance is transferred to the public
sector and and also in terms of water
and wastewater Airport privatization
alike we see great new revenue sources
that can be produced to help pay back
those fines that one of the biggest
lifts though I mean it seems to me it's
kind of like the shift from free TV to
cable TV you know it's hard to do and
now nobody would ever go back to free TV
I mean but is that it I mean is there a
turn there that we have to make that's
going to be hard to do well it will be
hard to do because there's a lot of
support in to the status quo right if
anybody had any idea how inefficiently
the public sector does capital assets
and I don't mean corruptly I just mean
efficiently so you you have a long
procurement to hire somebody to design
it long procurement hire somebody to
build it then somebody has to maintain
it probably the government right there
handoffs to each of those areas and so
all of those handoffs all that
inefficiency can become more efficient a
public-private partnership says here's
the here's the scope of what we want
the mayor says you tell me how you're
going to build it how you can maintain
it how you're going to finance it I'll
decide whether the service levels are
right the fares are right the fees or
the tolls and the services right well
we'll leave it there thanks so much for
talking to us Mayor Stephen Goldsmith
the recipient of the 2017 Reason
Foundation Sophos award thank you very
much for reason I'm Nick Gillespie
[Music]